Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to Seum,
now this is a speed-running game.
It's just the demo of it but
it's a speed-running, first person perspective game,
and what the means is, you're running through the depths of Hell,
probably away from your problems and
your family, and you're trying to get by,
trying to make the highest score you
possibly can so you can get on the
diabolical leader boards and then go
home?
Maybe?
Just like that but it gets much more
complicated, this may just be the demo
and is the only one that I played before
But, it's prob- what? Uh shit. I died
How do I die in Hell?! That doesn't make a
lot of sense but I'm gonna try my best
HA BIFF
HYAAA
AHHHHHHHHHH
Ohohohohoho
Hell yeah!
I think I did it!
I don't know what I- WoOoO I'm number twenty-three (23) on
the leader-board, that's kind of good.
Ok, let's try this.
So there's gonna be uhh, a few levels here and I don't, I don't know
exactly what I'm supposed to be- oh ohohohohoho
I just smashed headfirst into some spikes!
Ah shit! Alright.
Ha-boink all right there we go , ha-boinkie! Ha-booski!
Where am I going? Oh shit. YEAH. What did I did?
Ok, I wanna try that again. Hang on it's got to
be something else is like things that
you can.... EHHHH!
Ahhhh shiiiiiiiiit fuuuuuuck.. Hang on.
HUH-DUH! HUH-DUH!
Wow bum OK so... Oh shit!
Yeah!!! I did much better that time. I'm
gonna get the high score all over this
Hup. It's a trick! Oh god it was not a... WOAH!!
Okay I'm gonna be taking my time with
this one HUYUYUYUY-FU-OH-FUU! AHAAAHA!
Ah, god damn it, I didn't mean to do that,
that was mistake... Hup, Eeeeh-hup! Ah shit.
UP!! AAAAYYY, and FUP! Now I don't know why... Ah shit. Apparently I'm bad at this.
Who would've thought, HUP, HUP. Now I
don't know why, this guy is kind of like
a trucker in the middle of hell... And I
took the long way around, holy shit what did I do?
There must be another way... AHHH, that's the
stuff, okay I get it.
HUUAUHH!   HABASHKI! Yeah!
Alright let me try that again. Eh. Ohh, yeah!
AHHHHHHHHHHHH DAAAAAAAAAAAMN!
FYAH!!!!! Ok so I did that I'm number fifty-five (55)? I did
better the last time...
Fine, whatever, ah shit, alright, prison
escape. I don't know how to do this, HUP! Shit.
Heeeeeeeh, ah fuck. WHOOOOA!
It's a secret! Oh teleport ball!?
Wow beer! I had to get to my beer?! is that what I
said?!! I'm not a hundred percent (100%) sure about
that one but let me try that again.
HYA! Hup... Fuck... Whoahoahoa   I don't think this is right. Now that I know how to use it.
WOAHH! Yeah! Woah! Number four?! Hell yeah-hah-hah-hah. I can do that again, I can do a
lil' better.
Hup. Ah shit.
WOOOOOOAAH! YEEAAAH!!
FIRST (1st) PLACE, YEAAH! Okay that may not seem
like a lot to you, but any accomplishment
is amazing for me.
Alright, now it's probably gonna start
to get more complicated because we're
going to have a whole bunch of shit,
oh god ahh geez I wasn't ready.... Ah fuck. Uhp, shit.
*FUCK YOU SEUM*
AAAAHHHHH! Ah shitty tits! Hup!
Naahh, this is the worst... Oh, that was the worst, ninety-nine (99) plus !
Yeah, I know why 'cause I'm terrible.
Hup! Puuuhh..!  Aw shit. I got the power but not the
ability to do well in li-- Woah what the fuck was that?!
Oh, I think I learned a new trick. Oh I
forgot! Oh, that's going to be useful.
Okay, here we go. Hup!
Hepp Hup Hepp! Aw, shit... Hup!
Hup, Hoooh, hup! Ok, that's gonna be a thing!
Character in-game: "I got the powah!"
Whoa, WHEEEY QUEHH-PELL. Okay.
AHH! I wasn't ready! Oh god oh, fuck, I almost had that. That would have been legendary!
Hup HIP, CHIP, PUT, TIP. Aw shit.
*MUST CONCENTRATE ON DOING GOOD*
WOAAHHH!
Number eighteen (18)!? That did better. I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to do better on that one.
I'll try the next one! Ooh this looks fun! *a high-pitched voice*
It's just a bunch of saws!
Are they going to slice my buttocks?
Well, can't get me.. get me.... Ahhhh, they got me.
Don't laugh at me! You wouldn't laugh at
a guy with glasses would you? AHH!
Ahh fuck... scary.   So far, so goo.
AHHHAHA! Whoaa, okay. BOINK! Well, hell yeah. let's try that
again
I wanna at least get on the leaderboard!
That'd be nice. SWAYOOAAAAAH!
Ow my taint! Right on the blades.
Fuck a duck, fuck a duck, fuck a duck, fuck a duck, Woohoohoo!
AHAHA! W-- Aww come on..!
OW!
Character in-game: "Here we go again..."
OW. I thought maybe it was one of
those things where you can just run
straight into it... but apparently no-o-o-ot!
SHABAAAAM! Forty-two (42), I'll take it, at least it's the answer to all the questions in the universe...
What are you? Reverse gravity? that doesn't seem like... Whu-- Aw, fuck!
I  DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THIS! AGHHH! I need to watch the movie again!
Aw, fuck. HYUP! *Character in-game: "Gravity... Oh yeah, I can fly! Markiplier: HYUP!  Yeah. Yeeaahh!
Oh man that was terrible, let's try that
again.
Uh uh uh UH. Yeah! Still bad!
Heeeeyyyup!
Wheey, QUEAH!
All right. *Markiplier-style screaming*
where am I going? Where am I going? Where am I going? Idontknowidontknowidontknow!
*Markiplier does a thing* Good thing hell painted these convenient signs.
Ahh... I WENT TOO HIIIIIIIIIIIGH!
Habooskie! I...
Ha-boink! Yeah!! Way not even close to the
leaderboard! I'm going to skip that one
Come up on the final level! Holy shit,
charge?
Okay what am I looking for? AAAAGH! Oh god. AAAGH!
Oh geez, that's not good.
Character in-game: Hahahaha. Markiplier: Hahahahahaha. Ha-ho!
Ah shit. Alright, so I got to do a thing.
Oh boy. Ow.
Character in-game: Barbeque...
AAAAGH! NOOO! Hup.
Hep! Hep! Oh god that's, that's like off
sync!
Aaagh. It's not quite every. Bup! Aw shit.
Character in-game: Barbeque. Markiplier: HYAAA! Shut up about the stupid barbeque!
I ain't, I ain't. AAAGH! Fuck, this is gonna be difficult. BYAAAAA! KA-BOOSKIE!  HABOOSKIE!
Ah fuck.
Character in-game breaks fourth wall?: DAMN YOU PINE STUDIOOOOOOO!
Oh you can do short jumps! Oh, ok I'll, I
don't know why I wasn't able to do those before!
Hip, hip, hip, hip, HIP!
Okay we're going up, we're going up, we're
going up. PIFF!! I don't know what that that did but. AGHHHHHH!
Alright, lets try this again... HUUUH!
Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh
Okay, up, up, up, up. SHABOOSKI!
WOOOOOHOOO! Uh-oh, well that ain't good.
Alright under my butt. AIGGGH! FUCK YOU, FUUUUUUUUUUUUUUUCK! *the sound of rage*
Why, right at the end there? That's not COOL BRUH! Eh, eh, eh, eh, EH!
Ok, up, up, up, up, up , FABUSKI! GET IT, GET IT, GET IT, NAIL IT, NAIL IT, NAIL IT!
AAAAAAAAAGH! AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAGH! FUCK OFF! FUCK OFF WITH THIS BULLSHIT! This a bunch of bullll-shi-shit! Fire, oh I'm near...
JIIIICK!
HUAYYYYYYYYY! Ok... SWAAAAAB! OH COME ON!!!!!! FUCK YOU!!!!!!!!!
*Error- Markiplier.exe shutting down*
EHHHH!
FUUUUUUUUUU, ok, HEEEEEH, (Markiplier sounds) OK, here we go! HUP! WOAH-OH!
AND! BABY! YEAAAAAH! Number 18, I'll take it, I'm not doing that one again!!!
So that was... I believe... The last of the demo, and I did PRETTY OK!
I got number one on ONE of those levels, anyway, which is more than I can say for most of the games
that I play, now this may be just a demo. But this has a lot of potential!
I mean the demo's free, so you can play it right now and try to beat my highscore!
If you want, I'll put a link down in the description! Maybe I'll play when the full game comes out!
So thank you
everybody so much for watching and as always, I'll see you in the next video, BUH-BYE!!!
*Outro song*